イェーイ！！！
こちらのメンバーの皆さんと一緒に
パピプペパピコゲームというゲームをやっていこうと思います
よろしくお願いしまーす！！
（他のYoutuberの人達）よろしくお願いします！
はい、ルール説明でございます
（はじめしゃちょー）パピコ！
（Hikakin）ピピコ！
実際にやった方が
やっぱ、一番わかりやすいんで
（一同）お願いします
何隠してんのかなーと思ってた
負けた人はクラッカー飛んでくるんでー
気をつけていきましょう
(笑)
狙いどころですね ここは
ああああ"あ"あ”あ”！！！！
クラッカーがなくなったので
ここから負けた人は
風船爆発罰ゲームです
スピードを上げていきますか！
すぐ、終わっちゃいそうだけど・・・
今二回言ってたよね？
楽しいですね～
パピコ！パピコ！
ピピコ！
プピコ！
ペピコ！
ポピコ！
何度やっても同じこと
パンパピコ！
ピンピピコ！
プンプピコ！
ペンペピコ！
ポンポピコ！
何度やっても同じこと
パンパンパピコ！
ピンピンピピコ！
プンプンプピコ！
ペンペンペピコ！
ポンポンポピコ！
何度やっても同じこと
パンパンパンパピコ！
ピンピンピンピピコ！
プンプンプンプピコ！
ポンポンポンポピコ(?)
（笑）
もうなんかね、止まってるよね明らかに
パピコ！
ピピコ！
プピコ！
ペピコ！
ポピコ！
何度やっても同じこと
パンパピコ！
ピンピピコ！
プンプピコ！
ペンペピコ！
ポンポピコ！
何度やっても同じこと
パンパンパピコ！
ピンピンピピコ！
プンプンプピコ！
ペンペンペピコ！
ポンポンポピコ！
何度やっても同じこと
（笑）
はい！という感じの
パピプペパピコゲームでした～
すごい、みんなで楽しめるゲームなので
ぜひ！やってみてくだ...パピコ！
プピッコ(?)
パピコ！
ピピコ！
プピコ！
ペピコ！
ポピコ！
何度やっても同じこと
パンパピコ！
ピンピピコ！
プンプン(?)プピコ！
ペンペン(?)ペピコ！
ちょっと待って～！